hi everybody I'm Stevie um like Michael
said I'm an assistant professor I'm a
newer professor at University of
Minnesota so it's a great to be here um
and B great to be in a place where I
don't have to wear a puffer that goes
down to my knees to walk between
buildings um and so today I'm going to
talk to you um about the work that I do
in human centered AI for mental health
prediction on social media before I get
started though um I do have to warn you
and the audience that because of the
work I do on Mental Health um I'm going
to be talking about subjects related to
mental health with some examples in this
presentation um specifically I'm going
to be talking about and discussing
examples in the most General cases
related to Suicide as well as to eating
disorders there is one example towards
the end of the talk that is a specific
tweet of somebody who is thinking about
ending their own life if you need to go
take a walk or like not pay attention
during that portion of the talk I
totally understand I don't know the
difference between you need to take a
bathroom break and you need to just take
a walk for your own well-being I
encourage it if that's something that's
important to you so let's go ahead and
get started um at this point of my
career um most of us are aware that
there is a mental health crisis um in
the United States um about one in five
people um in the US in 2021 reported
experiencing mental illness um and that
would be what we consider like a
clinically like relevant level of um
distress and disorder um and then in
that same time period uh one in 20 in
the US experienced um severe mental
illness something that um therapists and
clinicians and psychiatrists would
really want to intervene in um something
that's affecting like dramatically
affecting people's lives and well-being
um and of those people um nearly 50,000
people in the US die by suicide every
year this number is way up from
historical averages um this has gone up
noticeably since 2010 um but um that may
seem big or small to you just kind of
depending on the context of which you
understand mental health um but one of
the most troubling Parts about this is
about 12 million adults seriously think
about suicide every year um and those
are the kind of people that many times
our clinical um as well as sort of
therapeutic interventions cannot reach
because they are suffering in silence so
people go online to try and communicate
about their well-being to talk to others
but also to reach out to trusted family
and friends to try and get information
about um mental health and to help them
just feel better um so I've been
studying this work since about 20 or the
work on Mental Health since about 2014
2018 2019 um social media companies
started rolling out AI systems that
would allow them to detect when people
were talking about what I call severe or
dangerous mental illness this is when
someone's talking about things that
involve physical or bodily harm like
Suicidal Thoughts um or self-injury um
and part of the motivation behind this
is for interventions for Content
moderation um but other platforms like
Facebook in this case actually were
trying trying to use it for prevention
efforts so in 2018 Facebook deploys this
algorithm behind the scenes that um
helps them identify when somebody may be
thinking about ending their own life um
they say it's run at the time by a
random forest model based on text
patterns in data if you're familiar with
this this is actually a pretty
lightweight easy straightforward model
um and they say that this U model was
able to get about 10 people every day
that weren't already reported by friends
and family on the platform for an
intervention and Facebook says that they
use this model to help identify when an
intervention might be necessary such as
sending people information about
hotlines or trusted support or
connecting them with resources to help
them work through whatever they're going
through and it's not just Facebook that
has these models on the back end um
Google X Twitter Reddit a lot of uh
companies actually have these kind of
models both for Content moderation
reasons as well as being supportive of
people who are in distress um and so I
think that these models and this
deployment ask like some really inter
interesting questions about like
building AI to detect this and so I like
to think about this in terms of the
consequences of what happens when we
make a bad system to predict um suicidal
ideation or some other kind of mental
illness um and the challenge here is
like building bad systems in this case
have technical consequences right it's
bad models we just get bad scientific
standards our performance kind of stinks
we don't represent the concepts that we
want to and so we don't actually
intervene in the appropriate situation
because we've gotten the answer wrong
and I think that there's a lot of risks
here about what might happen if you have
a poor model that predicts suicidal
ideation or depression or any number of
mental illnesses but and then one of the
things I wanted to mention is that a lot
of my past workor actually worked on
building better bottles for this so
during my PhD I spent a lot of time
trying to engineer ways that you can in
infer that somebody might actually be
suffering from elevated levels of
distress um and then thinking about the
consequences of building building that
so this is two systems that I worked on
from my PhD one of these is a multimodal
representation of Tumblr data where we
were able to take in the image as well
as the text data that came along with
this and then be able to predict whether
or not it was severe enough that
something might be taken down or require
an intervention another one um we built
was assessing people's mental illness
severity in the more General case on
Instagram using a data set of about 25
million posts and this figure shows the
rates of um severe content on Instagram
increasing over time based on our model
um and so one of the things that was
really interesting to me during my PhD
is actually proving you could solve
these kind of technical problems right
we can build some um models that deal
with these problems but as I moved
forward in my PhD and got closer to
graduation one of the things that
started really worrying me were the
outcomes of when we solve these problems
of poor models and making them better
and then actually deploying them in the
real world so this is just like two like
articles that have come up in the last
year about the use of generative AI in
uh mental health applications the top is
when Coco which is a chat bot started
generating responses um to people using
chat GPT and not telling them normally
Coco is done by um volunteers who like
directly counsel with you and talk to
you um and people got really upset that
4,000 people were like being helped by
chat GPT and nobody told them um even if
they thought that the care was actually
pretty good and then we also have this
challenge that um AI models that are
built on large data sets that move
Beyond just social networks across the
whole web are actually imitating these
dangerous behaviors and can be forced in
many ways to come up with these kinds of
ideas um and so in these cases I I get
really curious about okay so we can
build good models what are the kinds of
things we might expect them to do and
how might they behave in the wild and I
think one of the challenges with these
two is that these are a little
speculative right these are tiny like
small examples of when chat GPT and
other large language models running
independently may have negative
consequences but these consequences
aren't just like speculative like Tech
imagining with the fun of chat GPT this
is actually an example of a negative
consequence coming out of Amazon's
recommender system so this is uh two
substances that when you take them
together you will die um and these are
this is basically and I do not mean this
in any way to be crashed this is a
literal click to BU suicide cocktail
that was being propagated through its
systems because there was a group online
that was going to Amazon and encouraging
people to per purchase this pair of
symptoms a pair of substances Amazon
sees people continuously buying this it
says hey this is a good recommendation
to make to you if you buy substance a
you probably want substance B too um and
this was up on Amazon for six months
until and got reported on by I think the
New York Times twice um before it was
actually taken down and so these are the
kinds of questions I also wonder about
the consequences of good systems right
when we have stuff that actually works
um how are we actually going to handle
the fact that chat GPT May behave in
ways that are damaging to people's
well-being or when Chachi BT replaces
people in therapy what do we do and so
all these interesting ethical questions
come up in this work that are really
important to me as a computer scientist
to both acknowledge start thinking about
because I have the technical capacity to
do so and to try and solve um and so
this uh leads to sort of like the big
question you might not be surprised like
one of the things I'm real I'm really
interested in how you build and evaluate
um AI systems for mental health um that
are actually rigorous and solve the
problem we claim that they solve but are
also ethical and think about people's
well-being um as and their preferences
about how these systems operate in the
wild um so I'm going to show you today
about how my research kind of
contributes to a holistic vision of
human computer um AI or human centered
AI um to solve problems um and the
domain that I focus on is in mental
health and social media um but many of
these tools and techniques and insights
extend beyond just the case of social
media and mental health given their
focus on sort of socially contentious
sensitive issues you can imagine a lot
of these same questions about
appropriateness of tools good tools
being deployed in practice um these come
up in areas like Miss and disinformation
and political polarization toxicity
detection and prevention of harassment
in online communities um and sort of the
informal vision of my research that I
like to talk about when I'm not giving
like a very formal talk is how can I
serve humanity and make people's lives
better um while also making some real
really cool and impactful Tech too um
and this is sort of a combination of
both my interest personally in making
sure the tech that I build actually is
successful and empathetic and ethical
but also from my disciplinary background
I have an undergrad in uh media studies
in Comm and my graduate degrees are in
computer science and I feel really uh
impassioned to combine these two
together in human computer interaction
and AI research such that we can
actually do both at the same time and my
goal with this talk is to persuade you
you can actually do both as something
like a research career that you might be
interested in quick plug for my group um
they're the ones who are doing a lot of
this work for me at this point um this
we are part of group lens at as Michael
explained we are a old HCI group that's
been around since like the late early
90s I was not Alf Elementary School by
that point um but um they've been doing
uh groundbreaking research on
recommender systems peer production and
social media since the mate to mid 90s
these are my fantastic PhD students who
help me do all of this work and they're
really interested in all aspects of
human- centered AI for mental health as
well as other stigmatized identities
some of them are core AI researchers
like nerine who's at the top left he's
really interested in building AI Tech
that works outside of the global North
versus some of my other students do
interview work and work on social
science theory and think more about the
HCI ethics side of these problems um and
I like to give them a little shout here
because they're the ones who are doing
this work with me now um and are some of
the brains behind my operation um so
you'll see their photos pop up when
they're the ones who are kind of leading
the projects that I'm going to talk
about so it's an overview of um what I'm
going to talk about today I'm going to
Deep dive into this idea about data set
quality error and improving validity in
this um conversation because I think
it's an important issue that's sort of
emerged in the last five years um and
people really aren't sort of addressing
it in the way that I'm like kind of
personally satisfied about I'm going to
walk you through kind of a several
projects that kind of have like queed up
the the empirical technical work that
I'm doing which is sort of an analytical
Deep dive into the practices of the
field empirically showing that my
analytical argument was actually true
and then the technical kind of
brainstorming that I've been doing about
how to solve these problems also talk
about some work we're doing in building
and deploying interventions to help
people's mental health be better and
then going to wrap up with social
outcomes of HTI systems one thing I'll
just mention I'm totally happy to take
questions for clarification but this
talk typically generates some really
spicy and interesting ethical questions
and things that are like a little bit
bigger that can be answered in like 30
to 45 seconds and so if you have those
questions please write them down we can
totally come back to the end this Talk's
only going to take me about another 30
35 minutes so we'll have plenty of time
for Q&A
later all right so today we're going to
talk or I'm going to talk a lot about
data set quality error and improving
validity how many of you all have ever
taken an intro to psych or psychology
classes some experience in Psych okay
this is actually better than most most
of the time when I asked this in a
computer science audience um youall
might be familiar with this concept of
validity or the idea that the thing that
you're trying to measure actually aligns
with the concept that you have in your
head about it this is really crucial in
Psychology when we start to use this to
measure hardto Define Concepts like
social support personality and in
Clinical Psychology defining this idea
of and measuring Concepts like
depression and anxiety now towards the
end of my PhD after I was building all
these systems I was like yeah we can
totally predict these dangerous things
from uh mental health I had this kind of
moment of like wait am I actually doing
the thing that I said that I'm doing
with this work um and I wanted to go
back and reflect on practices that not
only I was engaging in but that I was
also replicating from prior work that
was receiving hundreds of citations and
driving the development of these systems
from places like Facebook and Google
behind the scenes so towards the end of
my PhD I got really interested in how
practice affects these decisions in the
papers that I was reading so I conducted
this gigantic systematic literature
review of research that predicted mental
health via social media data now this is
an ongoing project that my lab maintains
we currently we started out with I think
55 or 60 papers that was in 2018 or 2019
we got up to 75 papers in 2020 and 129
papers in uh 2022 and so this area is
rapidly growing it's very intriguing and
it's also a very interesting
interdisciplinary area where research is
in machine learning AI um natural
language processing HCI and health
informatics which is a huge spread of
work actually start to contribute to
this work um and so it was really
difficult to actually I I don't want to
underscore that oh this is a systematic
lit review where I just basically read a
lot of papers getting this in a way that
actually maps to the idea of what I had
took a lot of time I'm really happy to
talk to you about systematic reviews in
Q&A if that's something that you're
interested in but I'm just going to skim
the sort of methodology of this for the
sake of this talk so as I mentioned
earlier validity is a really important
concept when you're dealing like with
these kind of fuzzy difficult to measure
Concepts so in this particular data set
um we wanted to look at construct
validity which is a specific form of
measurement this is basically making
inferences from the samply particulars
of a study to the higher order
constructs of what they represent okay
that's like the textbook definition from
like one of the famous textbooks about
measurement let's talk about what that
means in your head you have an idea of a
concept you want to measure let's say
it's depression how are you going to
actually know that a person you're
screening in person has depression
everybody we probably need some kind of
agreed on ideas or Notions or variables
that might affect depression um and we
want to make sure that those are
rigorous construct validity focuses on
that first task that the ideas that you
have in your head actually can map in
some way to the real world and those
real world ideas can map back to the
ideas that everybody kind of holds about
this definition of depression they have
in their head now for my case what that
means is if we're trying to use social
media to measure depression does the
social media data actually represent
depression or does it represent another
concept and you might ask how do you
measure that now the way that we
typically do this in social media data
is with proxies proxies are an
alternative means by measuring a concept
when you can't actually ask a person
directly whether or not they're
experiencing the thing that they're
experiencing traditionally you would ask
someone in a clinical interview hey have
you been feeling down in blue for the
last two weeks have you had a lack of
emotions are you really angry these kind
of screening questions you or a loved
one may have experienced when you go to
the doctor and they're talking to you
about your mental health we can't do
that with social media users very easily
and even in studies where we can it gets
prohibitively expensive to get a large
enough data set to build a machine
learning model based on that data so we
use proxies instead and so one of the
things the systematic literature review
systematic literature review found was
the kinds of and varieties of proxies
that people said mapped to Concepts in
mental health so they would use things
like computer scientists who would go in
and say does this person seem like
they're depressed yes or no or maybe uh
they would use Community or network
affiliations like participating in a
Reddit subreddit about anxiety to say
that that person would have anxiety or
by using hashtags related to certain
behaviors or disorders they also would
look at things like personal self-
disclosures of diagnosis administering
screeners and questions to people if
they had the time and resources to
keyword matching this leaves me with the
question though okay you have these
Concepts that you say that you were
using to measure mental health do they
actually represent mental health and I'm
sure you're starting to Stew in your
mind of like oh does everybody who posts
to r/ depression are they actually all
depressed now there's a lot of reasons
to believe that those people are having
valid symptoms that are distressing them
right we believe that these people when
are posting for help are actually
distressed but if you care about
predicting the outcome which is
depression specifically they may not all
map to that narrow construct of
diagnosis they may actually in fact have
some kinds of anxiety bipolar disorder
which manifests as depression for some
people over like short periods of time
before they enter manic episodes they
might also have just other conditions
that are not related to depression they
may be asking on behalf of a loved one
right it's hard to know from some of
these sources whether or not they
actually generalized and so we were like
well do people even address this in
their arguments now I've talked to you
about the depression example but the one
that I think is actually most salant and
concerning to me is anxiety um I
personally have anxiety um and it's
something that I have to manage through
uh therapeutic um processes um but when
I was looking at papers that were
talking about predicting anxiety none of
them specified what they meant when they
said anxiety which as somebody who like
has a clinically a clinical disorder of
this was like wait wait wait wait wait
you don't even tell me how you predict
this you're not telling me how you set
this up because anxiety can be a symptom
that influences both some anxious Trends
but also other mental disorders like OCD
um it can be a transient emotion that
people experience right I'm a little
more anxious than normal because I'm
giving a talk it can also be lay usage
when you have a friend that you might
refer to oh like man she's just like
anxious don't worry about it right or it
can actually be a category of nervous
disorders of which generalized anxiety
disorder is one of several different
kinds of anxiety disorders nobody in
these papers mapped the fact that #
anxiety could map to any of these four
definitions and you can imagine people
using hashtags in different
circumstances to talk about all four of
these different examples and what we
found was that nobody actually defined
what they meant by anxiety when they
measured it from the data and this was
true across the vast majority of studies
of mental illness and machine learning
now this was in 2019 we've repeated and
looked at these results in the future
and we still find similar things um and
the challenge here is like if nobody
defines what they mean by anxiety and
they say they're actually predicting
this outcome it's really hard to know if
the system that they've built actually
works to predict the thing that they
care about and what we did is in
follow-up work we actually looked at
whether or not uh these kinds of
practices were actually happening across
more papers and we looked at like sort
of practices related to disclosing data
source the kind of information we'd need
and what we found is this is in 2023 um
Lee actually showed that these practices
are becoming more normatively implicit
basically that when disclosure happens
across groups of papers people in the
future will start to do the same kind of
disclosures and replicate prior work now
this is really good when you have things
like IRB disclosures and consent and
anonymizing people correctly in data
sets to make sure that their data does
not leak into um other kinds of models
but this actually can be really really
uh damaging if practices of a lack of
disclosure are not getting reported and
people believe that not reporting on
information is something that's standard
in the field now one of the things I so
this is kind of good news right we have
this practice where people are like more
and more reporting on different ethical
practices unfortunately like the data
sourcing and inclusion are being
reported more but unfortunately people
still didn't buy the risks of this
argument that I was making from the
analytical kind of analysis that I did
in the systematic lit review now I just
want to be clear these are paraphrased
and slightly editorialized comments I
found um about the fin that I just told
you about um but people have sincerely
told me these things that may be like
well it doesn't actually matter if the
concept measures the thing that you
claim it measures right our performance
doesn't lie we're getting F1 of like
0.91 .95 with like accuracy that's like
super high and like some people were
like but llms will just like solve this
problem right if you just shove it into
B I literally got this in a paper review
if you just put it into bird it would be
fine um and then the other one was like
it's the best data that we can get give
me a break I'm trying to solve a really
hard social problem I should have the
flexibility of possibly that data making
these errors now I have a feelings about
this unsurprisingly um and this like
leads me to this interesting question of
whether or not when we use like complex
machine learning architectures like llms
or Bert or other kind of Transformers We
actually can erase the problems of the
data and so these arguments were
basically running against the classic
notion that we teach in like computer
science 101 which is garbage in garbage
out right that the qual quality of the
data that you put into a system
necessarily affects the quality of the
inferences and the outcomes that it
gives um and this actually these these
comments were not just Lev in reviews
but also in job talks where people were
like no it's totally fine just like
throw an llm at it Stevie it'll be
totally fine so I was like all right
hold on I got this so um I actually got
really really annoyed and wanted to
prove empirically that this Downstream
process actually mattered so that people
would buy the empirical consequences of
this data actually affected the bottles
themselves so what we did is we looked
at one of the most popular and sort of
clinically gold standard proxy signals
which is diagnostic
self-disclosure um this is when people
go online and say I have been diagnosed
with a specific disorder now the reason
we love this disclosure is because
people are almost always honest about it
mental health is stigmatized and it can
take a lot for people to admit when they
go through stigmatizing or shameful
experiences side note I don't think that
mental health should should be
stigmatized but it still is something
and so we look for people when they talk
online that says I was diagnosed with
bulimia and we know that this is a high
quality signal so let me show you how
the inference like typically goes in the
machine learning process so we want to
be able to find people with eating
disorders in the whole world because
they're often undertreated
underdiagnosed Eating Disorders are very
dangerous when they go unchecked we then
say okay we know that we can get people
with a diagnosed eating disorder um and
then we look at people who disclose
eating disorders in social media data we
then can get this data from lots of
different sources including Twitter and
Facebook and Tik Tok because people will
disclose this and then we get our
training data which is that like shaded
area in the middle and then we can use
that training data as uh info to be able
to infer back to at least the blue
circle but we our goal is to actually
infer back to the whole purple circle
and that we've built a model because we
know these people have an eating
disorder we can generalize this back to
find other people in purple that aren't
in the blue circle um and this is a a a
kind of common setup in these papers
where the idea is like you can't get the
data directly so we use the social media
data and then generalize it and this
goes to the problem of what I was
mentioning earlier if people being like
Oh the data will just be fine and me
being like wait wait wait we don't know
that this actually measures the purple
circle so this project was an audit to
show that you could actually measure the
purple circle so the question that we
looked at was are these gaps caused by
the that the field operationalizes the
training data into the models themselves
and do gaps come up in the validity and
integrity of those models yes they are
very hard to detect though because it's
easy to uh cover up their gaps with high
technical performance which gets to the
point that that person was criticizing
my work from previously of well the
model performs fine clearly it's working
well um and we do this through an audit
that the training data actually has
really damaging contextual gaps that
compromise the validity of the model and
so let me walk you through how we got
this data how we ran our little audit
and the one of the examples of these
contextual gaps so that you understand
kind of the the problems that we get
when we sort of do this like training
data inference so as I mentioned um
self-disclosure is uh one of the most
common ones and part of the reason it's
so loved is because you can build a
regular expression to get it very very
quickly so we modified and like
basically improved on state-of-the-art
regular Expressions that are used to
find this data um for those of you that
have never used regx um it's a really
really nice um open kind of flexible
string matching protocol where you can
set up kind of very loose um string
matches to be able to find um people
like text matches so it's really good
for finding and identifying repetitive
um text like uh phone numbers and emails
and you can leverage it to look up I was
diagnosed with bulimia and that's
exactly what we did we F came up with uh
self- references of saying that it was
me who was diagnosed variants of the the
way that you could say diagnosed in the
English language um and then a list of
disorders and slang terms that people
use to refer to being diagnosed with
those disorders so Anna and a an is
anorexia or anorexia nervosa so a an um
BN and bulimia osfed and Ed are sort of
the general um all-encompassing terms
for eating disorders and we were able to
do this multi-round um refinement on the
regular expression with human labeling
to make sure that the quality of these
um the regular expression matches were
actually very high quality so we went in
did probably a process of five or six
iterations on this to make sure it was
perfect and then we went through and did
a human annotation and got an F1 of
about 085 now what's interesting here
that I don't um report on specifically
with a table is typically regular
expressions are a high Precision
activity um our precision and recall
trade-off for this F1 was a lot tighter
than the state-of-the-art baselines
which means that we had less false
negatives than other people who had
implemented this meaning that we could
trust that our regular expression was
not pulling in erroneous data when it
made these matches so we looked at the
self-disclosures and said yes these are
all people talking about being diagnosed
we're really really confident of that
then what we did is we set up a machine
learning experiment to see if these
problems that we had in our head about
validity actually propagated through
these models so what we did is we took a
data set of posts from atic Community
I've anonymized it to r/ community d
it's an eating disorder support
subreddit that gives people a neutral
space to talk about disorder and doesn't
allow for Content that would be sort of
pro or advocating for disordered eating
behaviors of the training data we H
found 292 users who had a diagnostic
disclosure inside this community more on
that number in a second and to match the
field sort of testing protocols we found
historical data from 292 random users
with no diagnostic disclosure now we
selected this kind of random baseline
from the same Community to to make the
prediction task kind of artificially
harder right if your goal is to check
the validity of the disclosure you want
to test this against the possibly
closest community of negative results
which would be people talking at an
eating disorder community that have
never said that they have an eating
disorder and then the reason that we
want this is because then we have high
confidence that a model that can make
these distinguishing characteristics is
actually honing in on people we have
high confidence have a diagnosis which
is that clinical certitude we want to
replicate in the
model now we pre-process this by
removing the regular expression word
matches from our um Regular expression
that I showed you before this isn't this
we do this to basically like avoid
cheating the model by saying oh if you
mention the word diagnosis it should
automatically be classified into the
positive this would are the positive
class right and we do this partially to
get at those more latent signals of what
it's like to be diagnosed with an eating
disorder of people talking about that
experience we run um we treat the model
details as well as as the um like
classical statistical model as a
hyperparameter um and we select models
that have interpretable features so like
uh binary uh logistic regression um svms
with like a oh I'm totally blanking on
the Kernel name but it's the kernel that
actually produces like interpretable
features out of it as well as random
Forest because we can actually Intuit
the features yeah just a couple details
sh with you um
the is it predicting off of all posts
from the sing yes it's predicting off of
a historical post the before the points
that they mentioned that they've had a
diagnosis
everything before and that's the idea
there is um most setups in the space
we'll use historical data of emerging
symptoms or behaviors or cognitions that
might indicate that somebody is leading
into being diagnosed and then what how
do you match the before negative um we
try and get a Time base match so we find
somebody at that we look in their whole
post data set to make sure they don't
find a disclosure and we try and time
match it approximately so we have
approximately the same volume of post
and give so the other question is given
the membership in that condition on the
membership of the community negative
data doesn't mean negative diagnosis
exactly exactly okay but the goal is to
be able to build a clinically specific
classifier where you have high
confidence that the positive data is
actual clinical certitude and so these
these kinds of setups you're kind of
poking at some of the intellectual
challenges with these setups um the goal
is to artificially make the task harder
cuz like an easier task would be taking
the negative data set of like 300 people
from like all of Reddit that have never
talked about an eating disorder right so
just to make sure I'm with you the
negative data could be people who were
dis who were diagnosed with eating
disorder but just haven't disclosed it
so this is predicting whether they will
later disclose not necessarily whether
they Havey sort yes okay yeah and so
it's an interesting the setup here is
replicating the state-ofthe-art kind of
way that we set this data up um I agree
with you about the limit like the kind
of implicit limitations that might be in
a setup like that um and that's part of
the reason that like the the critique
that I'm about to make actually pops up
because of these problems um okay so
just one very quick question uh it says
anonymized eating disorder what does
anonymized mean here because if it's
anonymized how do you know they're
previous po oh so when I say anonymize
um the community that we study actually
requests to not be identified in papers
they actually have it very clearly in
their rules that they'll let you do
research but they don't want to be
mentioned by name the other content we
anonymize by removing people's usernames
um and any identifying data in the post
where they may mention other subreddits
or other people so that um their um like
personal like usernames don't go into
the data but when I say anonymized I
mean I'm not going to tell you what the
subreddit is sure so the uh we ended up
also testing this with five crossford um
fivefold cross fold validation um just
to make sure that our results were
consistent given the size of our data
set right 292 users is not a lot of data
and you might expect a lot of variance
just depending on how those users might
be sampled so what we ended up finding
was that a regularized binary logistic
regression ironically kind of worked the
best um to be able to differentiate
between these two classes of people um
in this community we were able to get an
F1 of like 0.91 and a balance Precision
recall um and area on the curve
basically we we kind of matched
state-ofthe-art and being able to
predict and differentiate between these
two groups of people and to Michael's
point it's actually pretty impressive
that we can differentiate so much
between people who are diagnosed and say
that they're diagnosed but are existing
in the same Community as the people in
the negative data set which are also
talking about eating disorder symptoms
and things um but the challenge when you
set up the positive data set like this
actually comes out when we start to walk
through issues with these contextual
errors that we found in the classifier
one of them is this idea of temporality
um so I gave you this example earlier of
I was diagnosed with bulimia several
months ago that means we can use the
data from behind this disclosure the
first one that they make and say okay
this is like information up until the
point where they disclose that they have
a diagnosis right well no this person
points out that if I think I were to get
diagnosed again I'd say I have binge
eating disorder so this actually leads
to a really interesting question so when
we looked at the blue in our regular
expression check this is a diagnostic
disclosure this person clearly at some
point has
bulimia now they're just not sure and
it's been several months between those
points it's a really interesting
question though of what disorder should
we put them in a category of is
classifying across all eating disorders
good enough for this work or do we need
to now separate into bulimia and
anorexia neosa and binge eating disorder
and specificity and disambiguate this
specific example in the worst case
though we found that our diagnostic
disclosure signals worked really really
well but now are not actually temporally
relevant at all for our data right this
person says that I was diagnosed with
anorexia when I was 16 now I'm 28 now
there's been 12 years of data that we
could in theory use going backwards but
the problem is we don't even know if
that 12 years of data is actually
relevant anymore this person may be in
recovery and by classifying them into
the like disordered category the last 12
years of data may actually just be wrong
and you may be thinking oh well what if
you just like did some like evaluation
of the time of when they said this right
you could like go through this and find
several months ago and I'm 16 now I'm 28
and like discount these examples
remember we only have 292 examples
um and this is actually like a really
really big problem when you start
imposing qual more additional quality
signatures on this tiny little data set
and this is 292 examples of 70,000 users
in this data which raises really
important questions about the
representativeness of people who
disclosing an eating disorder for them
if they have an eating disorder but then
also imposes this kind of like pressure
on people building models when you like
okay we want to do the time sensitivity
analysis that I just
mentioned now our data it's going to
have 30 people 20 and we started to do
this analysis and realized like you'd
end up with like maybe 10 to 15 examples
of somebody that in that moment had
received a diagnosis and was trying to
work through what was going on and so
these problems of temporality in our
data set just like completely blow out
and cause this like error that's really
really hard to catch if you just looked
at the performance of uh these or the
performance of the model and what's
interesting is we actually found that
the time words appear as crucial
information for predicting whether or
not somebody actually had a diagnosis
what we realized is that people would
often talk about and give narratives of
diagnosis as important part of their
eating disorder Journeys that might
involve the diagnosis changing or them
moving into recovery you can see in pink
that all of these time words now are
becoming these like Salient features of
the model when we all can see that like
time words in this case actually
our ability to reason about the validity
of the data set I was only able to show
you one of the contextual errors here
but we actually have some really
interesting contextual errors that
happen in the negative data set where
people talk about very severe and
dangerous symptoms that would indicate a
very severe eating disorder diagnosis
but they never said that they were
diagnosed and so no data sets ever going
to put that person into the clinically
specific diagnosed category and so this
is actually the outcome of our audit if
we return back to this like figure from
earlier that shaded area is kind of the
data of what we think that we get when
we have a model that identify these
disclosures so what we think that we get
is here and this is the actual training
data that we get we actually get more in
this green area and I I would argue that
with the other sort of contextual errors
like this green area gets kind of Muddy
and blurry and really really like Blobby
the training data that we actually get
is people who say that they have
disclosures but that we can't actually
verify if they have a clinically
relevant eating disorder the time that
they say that they do and then what
happens is that our AI inference
actually kind of blows out out into this
area that we can't use it to reason
about even the Blue Area anymore but we
certainly can't use that to reason about
the purple area and this is a really
really popular signal in our data set it
was used by like 20 or 25 papers which
like is a fifth of the of the Corpus it
was highly regarded by people as being
like this clinically relevant and valid
way of looking at disorders but the
problem is now this work raises the
question of well were they actually
predicting back to the blue and purple
circles or did what they predict made a
really really high quality predictor
that's predicting this like kind of
Blobby area we can't actually reason
about its Effectiveness so I've shown
you some of the like empirical ways that
we were we've proven people wrong about
this work I'm going to throw out um sort
of four Solutions we've been thinking on
how to solve these problems um one is
thinking about other ways to triangulate
data sets so I don't want to totally poo
poo like people who go online and like
disclose the fact that they have an
eming disorder ERS like we believe them
right they are high it's like high
quality information of trustworthiness
about this information but we know that
it can't generalize back to the larger
category of people with eating disorders
so now I'm trying to think about well
how could we actually leverage the small
um imprecise data sets to start
triangulating across different kinds of
information so people who post on hash
eting disorder or who are posting
generally in that e disorder Community
as a larger kind of like less
representative less precise sample Maybe
we can get a very small sample of
clinical data and maybe we can actually
use this data in concert with each other
to predict and make the green circle of
inference closer to the larger sample
now the challenges of this are like
really really high because each of these
problems here have their own
representation and bias problems that
have to be navigated when you start to
incorporate them into a larger model and
in fact the modality and quality of
these data sets widely vary and so you
might not be able to seamlessly bring
them into the same model unless you're
positive that they come from the same
time frame from the same Community which
hurts our ability in the field to use
and leverage all the data sets that are
popping up the other thing that we've
been thinking of is just getting better
data sets um and so one of the
challenges of our our labeling process
here was that there was sort of no
context in the state-of-the-art practice
for like identifying these temporal
problems that we identify and that's
because ambiguity and contextual
weirdness is to be expected when you
have to use a proxy signal
um and we also know that disagreement
between people is uh normal Mike
Shaker's work about medical experts
disagreeing about diagnosis shows that
people will actually using the same
clinical information disagree about
whether or not diagnosis should happen
and they're valid disagreements and so
one of the things we've been working on
this is Dan one of my PhD students is
actually building a system behind the
scenes um that can collect better data
for people doing work like this that can
facilitate labels from more
representative perspectives that might
help us make um better inferences about
where those like vend diagram circles
should be and how their data like is
actually composed um and I have a little
screenshot of the like example of this
that we're working on right now this has
to be an internal tool rather than kind
of leveraging out of the box stuff
because the disagreement and the
ambiguity labeling is just not something
that like machine learning labels like
handle right now and so right now we've
got like a little task of like is this a
blp or not to test like the work but our
goal is to eventually have this be a
place where like different kinds of
expertise can come in and say hey maybe
this isn't a diagnosis that I want to
impose on here or maybe there's temporal
relevance that should put it in a second
like position behind stuff that we have
really really high quality information
about the other idea that I've been
noodling on is like generating synthetic
data with llms you could imagine just
like firing like a really really good
prompt at chat GPT and say hey can you
generate me a thousand examples of post
of people who are suffering from
clinically specific examples symptoms of
depression you could also Imagine
strategically tuning this on our data
set or other data sets um I have mixed
feelings about this um part of it is
because chat gbt is a black box that I
can't go in and inspect how it's working
to verify that like kind of
psychological validity itch that I get
um but it does have this interesting
like appeal of like quickly scaling up
data sets for hard problems and Chachi
PT and other like large language models
use gigantic corpora that I can't myself
gather very very quickly and so there's
this like trade-off of using like
synthetic data not only in my context of
mental health but how you might use
synthetic data generation techniques in
other areas where you have small data
sets but have urgent need to sort of
scale them out um and then the last one
which is sort of like like spicy I'm
just mad about this is like why do we
always have to predict diagnosis right
like maybe we should just change the
prediction Target um diagnosis is a kind
of like myopic and limited Target
variable as I mentioned earlier like
like people who are coming to r/
depression and our eating disorder
they're sad they're distressed right we
we have other behavioral markers that
might actually matter for an
intervention that have nothing to do
with whether or not they meet a
clinically specific diagnosis of an
eating disorder if they say they're
engaging in binging and purging
behaviors why do we need to diagnose
them to give them advice and behavioral
interventions to help them and this has
been treated as the Golden Goose for
this area in this way that I find very
frustrating given the diversity of tasks
that you might leverage AI in the space
for but also the kind of policy and
interventions AI systems and their
decisions lead to such as content
moderation and intervention and so this
is a model from another paper that I was
working on where I was trying to kind of
mess with this idea of latent variables
for suicide crisis using Reddit data um
and you can imagine like multitask
setups towards inferred behaviors that
might actually better inform the kind of
intervention that you might take um and
these multitask setups might actually
help you use one model with a high
quality data set towards inferring
different kind of policy outcomes for
example you can imagine a model that
predicts very very dangerous or risky
behaviors um and recommends removal of
some content while other kinds of
cognitions or behaviors may not be
nearly so urgent and you might
deescalate the kind of like Target
outcomes that might be from that model
all right I've got a little bit more
left um I'm going to take a quick water
break are there any clarification
questions all right so I spent a lot of
time talking about this kind of like
conceptual analytical empirically
showing that I was actually right all
along work um and then kind of this like
brainstorming about technical ways um to
show these solve these problems but I
want to think a little bit about how you
might actually use AI systems to
intervene when people are being
distressed I've kind of speculated about
this a bit but I've actually gotten
really interested in doing this in
context and the context that's most
interesting to me right now is on Tik
Tok embarrassing question how many of
youall use Tik Tok or Instagram reals
okay this is actually way higher than
the last time I asked this question at
mallister College why is this
embarrassing to ask that okay some
people find using Tik Tok to be
embarrassing and they like don't want to
admit that they use Tik Tok I don't
understand it personally because like E
I use a platform like you might use it
completely differently than me but I had
three people who admitted it at
mallister college and when I was like
and how many of you are embarrassed and
didn't tell me that like several of them
shot their hands up um but Tik Tok uh
short form video um recommendation
engine um gives you one video at a time
right and you have no control over that
recommendation system um and so we
actually were curious about why people
were using the of Tik Tok to study um
What U kind of mental health information
was being pushed through it as well as
um how the curation of the fyp which is
that recommender um system actually
affected their wellbe and so we
interviewed 16 participants um and a Kai
paper that we published last year or I
guess this year it's still 2023 um what
is time post-pandemic
um and we've also got a follow-up study
about how people leverage multiple
social media platforms to find
information about their mental health
that's currently under review um but
what we found is you may not actually be
surprised that Tik Tok provides like
wonderful benefits to people that
delight and Inspire them but also harms
their mental health for many people who
use the platform that have mental
illnesses so on the same on the side of
benefit people loved the fact that Tik
Tok was organic and serendipitous and
gave them recommend commendations that
helped them see like into themselves but
also see respect and like understand
other people's experiences more
empathetically and they loved when Tik
Tok actually gave them information that
they could take to their doctor and say
hey um this Tik Tok video explained time
blindness to me in a way that I didn't
know that I understood I feel like I
have time blindness can I talk about
this with my therapist and used it as
kind of a springboard to help them
understand them themselves but the
double-edged sord problem is that people
talked about Tik Tok as this runaway
train of information that they have no
control over um one of our participants
says that I think a lot of the
algorithms run on chaos um so it runs on
whether emotion what emotion it can
elicit from the user um and so people
talked about how if they were dealing
with traumatic experiences Tik Tok would
just keep giving them more and more and
more people talking about their trauma
um and for people with PTSD or who have
triggers from trauma that the fyp
actually would trigger them and upset
them and their option was either to stop
using Tik Tok or to like keep scrolling
and playing roulette hoping that they
wouldn't see another video and they'd
actually get something more comforting
about cats or food or whatever and so we
were we've been working with um
participants now in workshops to
actually design what an intervention
might look like to stop those harmful
effects that I just mentioned while also
preserving some of those benefits that
people find from using Tik Tok and we've
been trying to figure out ways to stop
what we've called the or we've dubbed
this runaway trade the challenges of
this is actually pretty hard though
because people are very very defensive
in a good way about the benefits that
Tik Tok might provide um this is like
some of the things that have come up as
like identifying moments for
interventions do you like want to say
every 25 minutes you should stop using
Tik Tok to like refresh and like make
your brain happier or do you want to do
this in a contextual way how do you test
this on a real system when Tik tok's
really restrictive about its API usage
should we intervene in problematic
social media use patterns some of our
participants were like leave me alone I
don't want you to intervene I just want
to scroll um and thought that an
intervention in this case was
paternalistic and so built on some of
these ideas we sort of have two kind of
models that we're using um the top one
is the idea of a tab um where you give
people the ability to control the
recommendations that happen within a
given part of Tik Tok so you would have
like two fyps and one which you could
specify please don't put mental health
content in this I just want this to be
cats and cooking and like gardening
videos and another tab that you might
actually engage in with mental health
and people really like this idea because
it gave them the control to like both
isolate this information from each other
but to also interact with it then when
they were feeling like they wanted
different kinds of content the other
idea that we've um a participant floated
test was a Choose Your Own Adventure
novel so when like a context Laden
system detects that you may be down a
rabbit hole about content that might
trigger you it says hey what's up you
sure you want to keep doing this could
we um have some kind of button that say
deletes the last 24 hours of my
interaction history so Tik Tok actually
reverts its algorithm back before you
got down the rabbit hole in the first
place do you want to have a timed break
do you want to have some Choose Your Own
Adventure that says I noticed that
you've been looking at content that has
a lot of hashtags about mental health do
you want to swap over to a different
side of Tik Tok and have more
serendipitous interactions on not
serious topics and these are two ideas
from our participants um one of the
challenges we've been running into
though is like companies are making it
really really hard for us to access and
make do these kind of tests um Tik Tok
we do have research API access in my
group um but the research API if you've
never used the Tik Tok API before stinks
um it's really slow and you can't
intervene in the fyp at all um and they
don't even let you pull the fyp directly
for a given person um and then other
platforms that I've historically done
work on which is Reddit they like
clobbered their API access over the
summer and on the right is like Twitter
SLX who is now trying to charge me
$5,000 um a month to be able to gather a
million posts um which is a very very
slow rate for a researcher who may have
multiple students wanting to do
different projects and makes doing the
kind of work that I do really really
hard and so we run into these challenges
and we're trying to actively navigate
how we operate in good situations like
this now given that I'm a little
overtime I'm actually going to go ahead
and just skip my outro um but what I do
want to talk about is some of these open
questions that remain about ethics and
about technical challenges and about the
outcomes of what the kind of world we
want to see when we build these systems
and some of the questions that I've been
thinking about a lot are like what are
the requirements that we actually have
to meet when we make a performance
system like do we actually need the
performance of it to be a the accuracy
to be 95% if all predictions are going
to be run through people I don't know um
and who should we bring into this
process to make sure that we actually
have good answers um for these kinds of
challenges that we've been running into
are doctors the appropriate ones to
bring in when the intervention may not
actually have to have anything to do
with a clinician at all what are policy
solutions to protect people and then I
think there's this open question about
that my participant brought up should we
even design these kind of interventions
at all or am I just being a patronizing
researcher who thinks they know what's
best for people with that I'd like to
open us up for some questions thanks so
much for listening uh love to talk to
you about this
thanks all right we got some time I have
a quick question um going back to a
point that you made earlier ready around
um should we actually be looking at
diagnoses I'm sure you've come across
the new neworks where um researchers
take data take um behavioral data and uh
MRI imaging and come up with a
completely new mapping of symptoms and
diagnoses that hasn't grown the way our
our current diagnosis system has grown
organically over a lot time um and I was
wondering how maybe you can use these
newer mappings of symptoms towards new
clusters of diagnoses or or clusters of
symptoms to inform your work and how you
how you gather no that's a really really
good question I was actually thinking
about the like I think it's almost like
a multimodal exploration of how symptoms
can manifest both cognitively
behaviorally physically as well as like
neurologically um one of the problems
that we just have to deal with in mental
health compared to other areas is um
mental health diagnosis is like 150 200
years behind diagnosis of things like
diabetes and cancer um and the diagnosis
of mental illness for a really long time
was fraught with like social outcomes
and ramifications that you would be
institutionalized taken away from your
family or um inhumanely treated and
we're only getting to the point where
like homosexuality is not considered a
mental illness that was like literally
in the last 40 or 50 years um so I think
that there's a lot of innovation that's
really really great in this space and
mental health is just behind it's behind
in terms of like the ability to have
this like multi-dimensional
representation of what the concept is as
well as to know when the diagnostic
concept is even valuable to leverage
like I don't know if I inherently care
about diagnosis as the sort of like
golden outcome when we're trying to
predict if somebody may be talking about
content that threatens other people's
lives because they like provides advice
or methods or other things that are very
very dangerous um and part of my goal is
to just actually move away from
diagnosis is the only thing that we care
about could we have behavioral signals
could we have cognitive things that
people talk about to your point about
multimodality what other ways could we
enrich the data that we have about
people's well-being um to solve these
problems and it's something I'm am
interested in and am cautiously
optimistic might work cautious it like
depends on my mood i' say 55 45 right
now to my understanding about the
problems that you st about the problems
with the model I we started to talk with
is that the data syst that they operate
with are right because they are
interpret signals about people who have
a diagnos and not right um so the result
of mispredictions that my is are false
poses for the specific one I gave you it
is a false yeah more so than than POS so
um and one of us we thoughts about
perhaps it's better if we are more
forgiving of false positives as long
news
Recs so your idea is to not put put
people who wouldn't be diagnosed into a
bucket that would be diagnosed I think
that depending on the use of the system
that's true but I can think of a lot of
examples where the intervention or a
lack of intervention might have social
or legal ramifications so um if you
imagine a system that might predict um
high-risk behaviors and we have somebody
who's actually engaging in high-risk
behaviors but is not classified by the
system and there's an intervention that
somebody is socially responsible for so
such as Facebook or Twitter or a
research team that's helping um that is
a bad outcome for the system because
you're not actually delivering care to
the person that needs it um however in
systems like the ones that we envision
false positive rates are are like your
idea of like maximizing for false
negative rates may actually be more
valuable because you just have a much
more generous screenin process the
challenge with more generous screen in
is the labor that's required to execute
those effectively and empathetically and
in a way that's personal Iz to people
and so one of the downsides of like
maximizing that in uh content moderation
prediction specifically is like you just
don't want to give like content
moderators like double or triple the
amount of work because your system is
kind of Loosey Goosey thinking about the
concept you increase somebody's workload
and so I think that depending on the
outcome this is why I was trying to tear
like tease apart the idea of the
prediction and the policy outcome that's
applied based on the prediction you
change your prediction Target and the
kind of metrics you might optimize for
depending on the Poli seat that you use
and so you're right there are times
where you would want to like change
that all right I'll jump in so starting
with things like your thy paper you
start to articulate that you the kind of
paternalism that can happen when the
platforms try to in start to take action
here can either get pushed back on or
can feel like it's sort of being spied
on um likewise you know if I you if you
had some magic device that you just kind
of sort of go beep and like see mental
health like diagnosis of anyone in you
just pointed at them like that also
feels like
a you
know aomy right so I'm curious in
particular since the platforms like on
the other side get would get attacked if
they did nothing right like they could
have stepped up but they didn't or
whatever so I'm curious does the
medical literature or the field have any
Notions that are portable or
translational here around you know when
they will contravene people's autonomy
when you like are there are there things
how would you Advocate that the
platforms or the technologist who are
building these things ought to walk this
line do we wait for people to come to us
do we try to do this detection if so do
we like say hey friend like is there an
issue do you like what do you actually
yeah that's a if you were designing the
product what would you do that's a super
good question especially because my my
mood changes depending on what we're
doing and how it's going to be leveraged
and the social outcome that might be
imposed on a person when that outcome
happens now the medical literature
typically believes that it is
appropriate to intervene um and violate
your autonomy when you are a threat to
yourself or to others um people in
suicide crisis forms often talk about
being 5150ed which is being
involuntarily committed to a ssy for 72
hours to make sure that you are safe to
yourself in those cases it's pretty
clearcut that the threat to yourself or
to others is enough to overcome the um
value of autonomy that has been
advocated time and time again for in
patient um centered care which is the
the current model that we use in the
medical system or at least are moving
towards a bottle of patient- centered
care um there are other circumstances
though where medical professionals
believe it's important to intervene but
may um sort of navigate around issues of
autonomy so I mentioned specifically a
threat to yourself or others there's
certain things that people may disclose
like child abuse or other sort of
abusive patterns that trigger mandatory
of reporting requirements um the
challenge is that the the medical folks
I've talked to want these kind of
systems because they don't have enough
money to provide the social support and
personalized care for every individual
and so the question is well can you
provide a larger group of people a
slightly more elevated experience of
care to give them some basic resources
rather than being able to have the
resources necessary to give everybody
comprehensive care and my ideal world we
would have way more money and way more
providers and way more psychiatrists so
we don't have month-long weights and so
in my head I have to trade off the
autonomy versus um uh intervention
argument that I mentioned before but
also this idea that the medical system
cannot handle all of this right now in
any country to be very clear and so my
personal stance on this which I'll just
mention is a personal stance this is not
a clear-cut um decision is that by
providing different and escalating
levels of interventions to people such
as a nut not a nudge because nudge is
psychology is debating whether or not
they actually work right now or not but
like different kinds of interventions
such as the Choose Your Own Adventure or
giving people tabs may allow people to
actively and pro like proactively manage
their own well-being same thing with
like lightweight therapy Bots that may
give people like cognitive behavioral or
like DBT based like interventions that
might actually make their better until
they can get into the therapist and so
the social responsibility of that
towards question about like well what
happens if you're wrong who is
responsible when the AI system is wrong
what severity of wrongness does that
entail like in the case of like somebody
streaming a suicide video on Facebook
like this does happen like getting that
wrong is really really bad because it
encourages other people to harm
themselves and you probably want to take
action quickly and swiftly on those
versus like lower grade could call it
like markers of distress you may
actually have like lower Pol like lower
thresholds of policies for like low-key
interventions but that people can like
more easily like sort of swipe
away yeah so digging in a little bit
more to that and kind of a specific case
I'm I'm curious if you think that having
interventions that become known about
may change how much people are able to
seek social support online so especially
thinking if are ever you know like
detected suicidal ideation leads to
involuntary
institutionalization and thus this
outlet that people previously thought
was kind of safe from this mandatory
reporting no longer is and people don't
seek the the support that they like
maybe don't even go to their therapist
for because that space is no longer safe
as well yeah yeah no that's actually a
really really um challenging point
because Facebook has has these models
that work behind the scenes and they
also give people the rights in groups to
ignore the platform specific rules so
that people can like modulate some of
these rules so that they're not enforced
on the group itself so I actually like I
don't typically like compliment Facebook
on decent policies but like that one was
actually pretty good to give people
space to talk about these kinds of
things um I also think about the like
opposite kind of version of this where
people may overly rely on these
interventions instead of actually
seeking out more comprehensive care um
and I don't think that that's like a big
spooky Boogeyman that the media is kind
of making out to be right now like oh
like AI is going to replace your
therapist like no no it's not it it like
is not nearly as good as my therapist or
many other therapists who have years of
training um but I like to think about
this in terms of the
like what kind of infrastructure do we
need to maintain this space as safe if
we are not going to leverage these
Technologies to make them more safe so
there is a website that I'm not going to
tell you the name of it is a very
pro-suicide website um and they're the
ones that that recommendation was making
the Amazon uh click to buy thing um it
was from that website specifically that
they propagated that um they don't have
aggressive content moderation they are
very adamant about free speech and the
stuff that they share on that website is
incredibly dangerous and like I I do not
want to tell you about it because like
it's very bad and in some cases think
that the AI systems in those cases may
actually support like a better dialogue
so that it may like blur out or remove
some of the most dangerous stuff without
preventing people from sharing their
thoughts and feelings which that
expression of it is really really
valuable there are other sort of more
contained spaces that I think are good
models for reasoning about this r/
suicide watch is a suicide Crisis
Support Forum they have very aggressive
moderation policies about mentioning
things that may trigger other people to
commit suicide specifically like methods
means and plans um but they do an
amazing job at giving people the space
to talk through their suicidal ideation
in a much lower judgment space and in
those cases you might design an AI
system that just really goes after those
very very damaging ones and then let
human moderators manage the rest and so
I don't think AI is sort of this like
Silver Bullet for solving the complexity
of nor the Nuance of mental health
situations nor making it a safe space
for people to be able to continue to
talk all right I'm going to pause it
here but there will be some time to ask
questions afterwards as well check our
speaker